dans le cadre de la semaine olympique et
paralympique le creps ile de france
organisée cette semaine des activités
pour les classes de primaire
ce mardi 2 février c'était découverte du
golf au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines première
activité qu'on a fait et va on devait
dire déboulé avec les balles ces voix là
et est la deuxième on apprend des ti des
petits secrets pour tirer au mieux dans
tron que c'est la première fois que je
du golfe est il même si j'arrive parfois
très bien
en plus des différents jeux ludiques une
visite du 18 trous qui a accueilli la
ryder cup 2018 et sites olympiques de
paris 2024 les jeunes sur les lieux le
fort de de marne
on a maintenant voilà les champs
jusqu'aux jeux olympiques pour pour
préparer pour les sensibiliser pour leur
montrer que voilà sur la sur la commune
de saint quentin en yvelines mais voilà
il ya magnifique outil sur lequel ils
pourront pas j'espère un jour voir
demain pratiquer le golf donc c'était
très bien en vue de les accueillir comme
parrain de cette semaine olympique et
paralympique le jeune à carreaux avaler
16 ans connu pour son combat pour
l'insertion professionnelle des
diabétiques
il intervient auprès des jeunes pour les
sensibiliser sur la thématique du sport
santé à chaque classe j'essaie de les
sensibiliser par rapport à cette maladie
donc moi même je suis diabétique de type
1 depuis quatre ans maintenant et donc
je les sensibilise par rapport à cette
maladie à la gestion cette maladie au
niveau du sport et aux bienfaits du
sport pour les personnes diabétiques
mais aussi non diabétiques parce que se
permet on devrait vrai équilibre au
niveau du fonctionnement du corps au
total ce sont plusieurs centaines
d'élèves répartis tout au long de la
semaine pour cette découverte sur le
green du golf national